another hot one here in the desert but
uh pretty comfortable here inside chase
field where the diamondbacks are taking
on the san diego padres
it is the left-hander alex young his
first start this year filling the
rotation spot for the injured madison
bumgarner tommy pham leads it off for
the padres and
swinging a miss
good start for alex young there's that
sinker and now it's machado
right there ring him up and sit him down
two batters two strikeouts
after a series of sinkers away he comes
right back in on that inside corner two
down here in the first inning and
fernando tatis jr in his new spot in the
order batting third
this one is ripped to left field high
deep and that ball is gone a home run
fernando tatis jr with his ninth home
run of the year puts the padres on top
one to nothing good way to start
tonight's ball game in the desert here
is cal quantrill
in the rotation for the first time this
year cole calhoun leading it off now
ready with a 2-2
and he elevates to strikeout calhoun
that'll work fastball up at 95 and
calhoun strikes out to begin the bottom
of the first inning well myers
batting for the first time as he leads
it off here in the second inning
this one is lying towards the gap in
left center field it'll get down peralta
cuts it off quickly and myers is
thinking too we'll see
throw is not going to be in time a good
throw and that would have been very
close but myers goes in not
[Applause]
starts off the available second against
cal quantrill not even counting pitino
and gore who they're going to bring up
eventually david slaps that into left
field big turn at first
and that's the first diamondbacks hit
tommy fam has come up a little bit lame
here
padres trainer heading out there he
looks like he's coming off i did not
notice anything to be honest on the
initial play
edward olivares is coming in here for
the padres takeover for fam tommy pham
coming out of this game
back-to-back games where we've seen
padres walk off the field
two down and peralta
is at third base there's carson kelly on
two pitch
and a swing and a miss needed that a
strikeout leaves peralta at third padres
have a one-nothing lead colton varshall
the dh leads off the third against cal
quantrill
punches it the other way
second time tonight the diamondbacks
have done that varsha with that speed is
in there at second standing up dalton
varshall a hustle double and now
swinging a miss and quattro gets out of
the jam works his way around the
lead-off double fernando taji's junior
in his first at-bat as the d-h he hit a
home run
coming back in got it by him fourth
strikeout for alex young who's now set
down seven straight they're loaded for
mejia base is full of padres and two out
on the ground to ahmed nick scoops it up
goes the short way and they just do get
the force on corner worth alex young
gets out of a bases loaded mess and
keeps it one-nothing san diego one after
altered first and here is christian
walker
and it is sent to center field grisham
going back
still going looking up and that ball is
going to be off the wall
peralta coming around third going to try
and score chronoworth's throw is good
one and the out applied francisco mejia
tags out peralta the out of the plate
nicely done we'll work to carson with
two on and two out
carson dunks one into right
this will get walker home
escobar into third carson kelly the rbi
single there's a big two out knock and
we're tied at one walker tonight has
line to center and doubled off the
center field wall
walkers hit the ball right on the barrel
every time up and he leads off the six
for the base hit houston has really
swung the bad well as of late well here
is carson
carson kelly there it is knocks it into
left field they will stop walker
and the bases are full with nobody got a
chance for nick now over two
base hit
walker's home they're going to wave
escobar
carson kelly digging for third they're
going to stop him there nick ahmed with
a big two-run double old calhoun 0 for
three
and they're right on schedule here
garcia bobbles it cannot come home
carson kelly scores and it's four to one
they had a chance to cut down the runner
at the plate but a little juggling act
there by greg garcia cost them a run and
ahmed is in at third base two down for
catel marte goes bunt can he get it by
stamen he does can tell there's a bunt
rbi single and it's five to one well
that was not a sacrifice he's trying to
fight for a base hit right here once he
gets it by stamin nobody can make a play
on that ball so first and third now with
one out and brings up carson kelly
and a ground ball down the third
baseline fair ball and machado's throw
but first base will be
in time he got him what a play by manny
machado from foul ground machado fires
it across the diamond to first osmo with
the good stretch run will score the
diamondbacks to take a 6-1 lead and
they're going to challenge this watch
that right foot we never got there never
got back chance for nick ahmed who two
on and two outs
up the middle and throw into center
escobar is home to make it 7-1
third rbi tonight for nick ahmed
takes us to eric hosmer
in the air to right center field that
ball is crushed back and it is gone
eric kosmer with his third home run of
the year here come the padres two outs
too bad two runners on for francisco
mejia
jammed him with that fastball in on the
hands carson kelly near the dugout
carson
hang on
carson kelly over the top rope to get
that one fernando tati's junior coming
up
tati sends this towards right center
field back goes calhoun and that's going
to one hop up and over so the double
will drive in two runs to get the padres
within two it's now seven to five tati
sits second base and the tying run
coming to the plate now we are to
continue and he lines one into center
field for a base head tatis being waved
around martay will throw to second and
it's a one-run game jerks and profar
mateo takes off that's a base hit into
the gap
mateo can fly gotta make this quick
they're gonna send them in here's the
relay from cattell
got it at home
and the diamondbacks win it